hello ladies and rejects the men I'm
Greg
this is Tara Erickson yeah say your name
Karen Ericson Tara Ericsson hashtag this
idiot hashtag this idiot
which is what all her friends called her
including me who just met her today yeah
this idiot over here oh gosh is so
terrible tell her horrible
I found her YouTube channel she is
really [ __ ] funny
Wow guys she's really funny hilarious
stuff on there she's friends with Amy
castle who's been on this channel to go
to her YouTube channel go to it right
don't even watch the rest of this video
no doubt there it's way more worse than
watching what we're gonna do right now
boom promotion problem hey hey there's
people who set this forgot to grab the
screen shot I don't need to keep
explaining that's it 20:17 trailer but
it's the Cat in the Hat I just showed
her the it trailer she was terrified I
would have recorded arms
Bonnie [ __ ] out why I rock it was it was
a good reaction on her end but only for
my peripheral I'm ready for this I'm
sure it'll be like Mike Myers is Cat in
the Hat let's do it
[Music]
there you go she's already
[Music]
sound effect not the phone well from
doctors sick terrified oh my god God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like really scary
[Music]
oh my god it's so good that's scary
no no scary who was this channel but
with our great job on that man yes yeah
loving it I thought it was just going to
be a hilarious it's like funny and scary
that's the same thing it's just the
scary as the other one I loved it I
loved it I was amazingly well done the
way all the little splices he did
whatever he put Mike Myers this cat in
that there that was so good really funny
the little subtle touches like from dr.
Seuss's I'm terrified
that's so funny so good and then he
called it the Cat in the Hat at the end
instead of it that was one funny trailer
is so scary at the same time it reminded
me just how scary this trouble so who
the heck you'd that little kid at the
end he's so good oh my god Tom I was
like six and full of rage he goes from
like really having a good time what a
kid's gonna be music yeah baby big kid
or that or that he's got serious rage
issues that child no child should be
able to perform that that well you're
having your imagination that's what I'm
saying I'm like woah okay he scares me a
little bit more than I knew the cat was
propping it up feel scared me when the
kid when you came against I run with the
hair zone the hairs the best part I
don't I mean that was like great editing
right there was a hair coming through
yeah that freaks me out Mike Myers cabin
had is pretty creepy actually I agree
like he's not for children it is kind of
disturbing yeah I I did shine cap the
looks like talks like a human yeah
should only be screened at 21 and up
yeah exactly
that's all the kids they run out
screaming my role my role well I think
the trailer was scary because they do
look kind of identical I totally agree
my paint color scheme the white the red
yeah the eyes and everything Molly they
look rather similar it's crazy all right
no more cotton hat but without
congratulations man I see your videos
doing really well subscribe to this guy
right away subscribe to the okay oh whoa
hey you subscribe to the real rejects
click that Bell yeah notification Bell
there's a note here that you can clearly
make out with the lights pointing at it
click the Bell is what it says and then
he drew a bell on there is to remind him
what about I was I had to forget what
I'm a visual learner also have like
ringing out of it like line wise well I
knew it
right this is vibration yeah Tara
Erickson go to her YouTube channel
follow her on Twitter follow her on my
back follow her anywhere you can follow
her if you see her in person follow her
follow her home around the corner she
lives yeah yeah follow her into her home
let's do that telling you guys it'll be
worth your time I'm down that's how we
met I got little crying my fridge let's
you know pop one of those and do stuff
let's not I mean new stuff let's not do
stuff I mean do stuff Gregor I meant
like do sit like ah make jokes that's
what I meant you you're supposed to be
though he told me yeah clean humor hey
make it make jokes is clean okay I can't
you guys are the ones with the minds
going everywhere not me blaming us real
region